now why are you Peter rich everything's
great how about you I am doing great
Mahmood that you made I just know one
how I was associated with ESPN for so
long it just felt strange even though I
wasn't thrilled to be with NFL Network
when that happened what's going through
your temples right now Peter I thought I
might be a little bit more emotional
than I then I have been last Thursday
when I told my staff that was an
emotional couple of hours but since then
I have been pretty much well life goes
on let's go
nothing lasts forever nothing should
last forever
and somebody's going to come along and
do it better than I did it and you know
I don't ever feel like people are you
know either irreplaceable or or or
whatever I just feel like there's going
to be a next it's going to be really
good and honestly rich I got nine people
who I have worked with for a few years
now at the mm QB and also ever olds at
Sports Illustrated and those nine people
their average age is 30 years old and
they're ready they they deserve to have
the kind of chances that I've had over
the years so there was a lot that went
into this including that including the
fact that the 24/7 nature of this job
just I just it's just it just never ends
and I've become less and less a fan of
that over the last couple of years so I
just think it's it's the right time and
it's a good time for me to make a move
and this DM MQB gonna still roll on oh
yeah yeah it'll exist and they will
continue to do great things and where
does your mmq be where can it be read
this fall for those who may not know
Peter well it's going to be like it's
gonna be in it's gonna be at NBC
sports.com in some way I don't I have
not really discussed that with a
right I mean record Ella who and it is
the digital space over there one of the
reasons I'm doing this I think Rick
Cordell is is brilliant when it comes to
digital media and so quite honestly my
feeling is whatever Rick tells me is
going to get us the most traffic and do
the most good that's what I'm going to
do you know does he knows 58 times more
than I do about what a space well you
know I had a conversation with Bob Lee
last hour Peter after he won his first
ever Emmy Award for studio hosting I
know right and and and how he was
talking about if something can't be fit
on a phone in our day and age of the
visual medium then it's not worth its
salt in the eyes of many who run the
businesses of sports broadcasting do you
think that there's writing on the wall
about the written word digitally Peter
well I mean I think one of the reasons
why I have been so bullish on making
sure that that the mmq be and my column
has been well read and we've spent a lot
of time energy resources and money on
those is because I just think eventually
this is how everybody is going to read
this how everybody is going to get the
news on the phone on the tablet on the
laptop and so I'm bad at predicting the
future since but I think it's been very
very clear for a long time that you know
the days of you know I sit with my wife
every morning in New York and I read
three newspapers in my hand and honestly
that I assume that I'm going to be the
last generation to do that Peter King
here on the Richardson show so if you're
poor predicting the future should I not
ask you about the Odell Beckham contract
and how John Mara said basically it'll
get done when it get
done and if it doesn't it doesn't and
this short or um I mean the contract I'm
pretty sure it's going to get done rich
I'd be very surprised if it doesn't get
done I think the the thing about Beckham
is I think Pat Shermer and Dave
gentlemen want to be around him before
they play in the contest it's more than
I've ever paid Eli Manning which and I
don't blame them
in the least I think it's a smart way to
go but and I think he will mostly be on
his best behavior over the next few
months and the contract will get done
well the issue is though as he might not
be around them very much because there
is no contract Peter right and then and
then when he plays and he that that's
usually when the Beckham crucible crops
up in anything that's negative based on
a touchdown celebration or a moment
during a game in all honesty that
usually it's the playing season whenever
something might crop up with Odell
Beckham that the video the three seconds
that happen in a Paris hotel room is
kind of the outlier involving yeah I
think I just think this you know the New
York Giants put up with Lawrence Taylor
for years through a drug suspension
through a lot of other things happening
in the wee hours that we never knew
about I'm sure they put up with a lot
with him they haven't put up with it
nearly as much with Odell Beckham and
I'm just gonna say this the thing about
Beckham that I think we all everybody
who who loves football and particularly
the people who love the New York Giants
everybody needs to be cognizant of one
fact and that is that Odell Beckham is
not a guy who gets arrested he's not a
guy who you know is is a DWI guy he's
not you know he's a he's an unusual
person
who sometimes finds it hard I think to
live within the strictures of a team but
that doesn't mean that you can't make a
long-term marriage with him and so my
feeling had you know through all of this
has been look you know there there have
been times where I say get rid of this
guy but most often I feel like the
calling is there the talent is too good
and the Giants history is to put up with
very talented people who were a handful
to handle and Peter King joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show the the Brady Met
Gala the outfit has knocked the Brady
pleading the fifth off the Brady radar
screen but where does everything stand
here I mean what is smoke what is fire
with New England Brady Belichick Kraft
you know I've not I've talked to Brady
this offseason so I all I can do is read
tea leaves like everybody else for
somebody who knows Brady a little and
that is Tom Brady's about to be 41 years
old he's coming off the season where
he's he won MVP at age 40 he had one of
the best years of his life he led his
team to a Super Bowl this is my feeling
this is not any message from Brady this
is not anything other than what I think
what I think is that Tom Brady probably
is a little bit tired after leading the
Patriots to a Super Bowl he's probably a
little bit tired of being treated like
Johnny Foxborough you know the second
year everything to proved quarterback
that's just my feeling I don't know that
but I think that's probably how I would
be feeling if I had accomplished what he
did and was being treated the way
apparently he's being treated which is
just like everybody else on the roster
right and that that goes back to the
trainer right that the trainer that's
what he you know Bill Belichick has done
something
Alex Guerrero that it seems anyway like
Tom Brady chase that but at the end of
the day rich I say this Billy Myers in
the athletic yesterday or today that
that you know really want business just
offseason crapola basically that's the
way I feel about this rich is that when
Tom Brady goes to whatever the mandatory
camp is I didn't even know when it is
sometime in may late massing when he
goes to that camp he's going to go and
as usual he's going to be the hardest
worker the place when he goes to
training camp he's going to set an
example for every one of the 21-year
little kids who shows up that weekend so
the way I feel about it is that there's
so much we cover in the offseason that
once Labor Day weekend rolls around we
say what does that mean absolutely
nothing and fitness for a long time
never one time ever and I heard somebody
who for instance who at the Scouting
Combine doesn't do X number of drills
and you've got te or doesn't work out
and says I'll work out on my pro day and
doesn't do something and and the NFL
teams are grousing about it and I've
never won time on graph day then heard a
team say what about the reason we didn't
take this guy is because he wouldn't
work out for us I mean it just there's
so much stuff that happens in the
offseason that is so what is it is it
Crapo or gorgonzola
Peter I mean last one then one last one
for you before I let you go into that
good Wednesday the Ben Roethlisberger
Mason Rudolph situation if you will
where Ben did not just essentially say
hey I haven't spoken to the kid yet but
I'll welcome to the team I'm just
focused on year whatever it is for me
and I just want to win more Super Bowls
here he basically talked about how
surprised he was and
now it's not you know and he made an
offhand joke that fell flat about you
know that they'll just point to the
playbook based on the fact that Mason
Rudolph said it's not his job Ben's job
to tutor him it just seems a lot of
unnecessary gorgonzola right there hi
dear I mean look I don't know expand
Roethlisberger actually feels that way
and action if that's the way he's gonna
be but if he is I think it's Bush leave
myself I mean a Robert Crumb call with
the mmcd this week wrote about how much
tommy maddox helped him and how Ben
Roethlisberger thanked tommy maddox
profusely after he helped them
phillotson and I just think so at some
point where all this burger is going to
I think Roethlisberger is going to
realize at some point that that you know
it's okay to it's okay to help somebody
it really is because you know what
that's what we're here for
you're here to make the to make the road
travel for the person who comes after
you and the Mason Rudolph is not here to
take Ben Roethlisberger's job Mason
Rudolph is here to train for the point
when Ben Roethlisberger doesn't play
anymore I mean I just I am not a fan of
how Roethlisberger handled that at all
well and Peter the the the testimonials
that everybody was tweeting out from
your former staff at the mm QB about how
you were helping pay it forward with
them means you walk the walk of the talk
that you just made and I just wanted to
say thank you for your years at the mm
QB and I look forward to the turning the
page Peter I look forward to that thanks
a million or it's really really
appreciate it's been great there it'll
be great here and like and life life
will go on and thank you you bet that's
a Peter King the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience